One of the core aspects of the ARIA
system is its collection of roles.
As we learned in lessons 3 and 4,
a role, an accessibility term,
amounts to a shorthand for
a particular UI pattern.
ARIA provides a vocabulary of patterns
we can use via the role attribute on
any HTML element.
When we applied role=checkbox in
the example earlier, we were telling
assistive technology that the element
should follow the checkbox pattern.
We're promising that it will have
a checked state, either checked or
not checked, and that the state
may be toggled using the mouse or
via the space bar.
If we followed the advice
in earlier lessons,
we've already kept part of that promise
by implementing keyboard behaviors.
In fact, since the keyboard
interactions feature so
prominently, it's very important to make
sure that when creating a custom widget,
the role attribute is always applied in
the same place as the tabindex attribute
so that keyboard events will go to the
right place and so that when page focus
lands on an element,
its role is conveyed accurately.
The ARIA spec describes
a taxonomy of possible values for
the role attribute and associated ARIA
attributes which may legally be used in
conjunction with those roles.
This is the best source of truth when
it comes to understanding how the ARIA
roles and
attributes all work together and
may be used in a way that is supported
by browsers and assistive technologies.
It's well worth browsing through the
list of roles linked from the instructor
notes, since there's a finite vocabulary
of roles which can be used and
each one has specific
semantic implications.
Also, in this screenshot,
we can see that certain roles
are designated as abstract.
These capture certain properties which
may be common to several roles, but
may not be used as values for
the role attribute.
The ARIA spec also has a section on each
role, explaining its semantic meaning
as well as any associated attributes
that may or may not be used with it.
Let's walk through these sections.
The top section gives you
the name of the role,
a brief description of
its semantic meaning,
as well as a brief description
of the related radiogroup role.
Then, in the table,
we start off with a superclass role.
The role's model includes a taxonomy of
roles, including some abstract roles,
which capture groups of roles
with common properties but
can't be used on their own.
In this case, the superclass
rolls are option and checkbox.
So radio button inherits
properties from both of those.
We also have a related concept.
This is just kind of a catch-all for
things that are semantically related.
In this case,
a radio input is related because it's
a common presentation of a radio button.
These inherited states and properties
are all the properties which may or
must be applied to this element
based on its superclass roles.
Most of these will be optional
generic global attributes.
But in this case, we see aria-checked,
which is inherited from the checkbox
role, is a required attribute.
So if we're going to create an ARIA
radio button we have to make sure
aria-checked is set correctly.
We have some information about
labels referred to as name here.
Name From indicates whether the name may
be taken from the element's text content
like a button element or needs to
be provided by some other mechanism
like a native HTML radio input.
Having contents as one of the options
here indicates that the element's text
content if it has any will be
used as its accessible label.
Author indicates that the author
must explicitly provide a name,
which we'll cover a bit
later in this lesson.
Accessible Name Required obviously
indicates you've got to specify some
type of name for this role.
This is usually but not always true.
For example, the main role indicates
the main region of a page,
which requires no
explanation in most cases.
And finally, the implicit value note
here indicates that the default value
for aria-checked is false.
This means that if we omit
the aria-checked attribute,
the radio button will be
represented as being unselected.
It's definitely worth learning
to navigate the ARIA spec
to find out about the specifics of
ARIA roles, states, and properties.
But if you can find a specific pattern
you want in the ARIA practices guide,
then that gives you all the information
you need to implement the widget
in one place.
It also links back to the ARIA spec for
information on all of the ARIA
attributes I've mentioned.
Earlier we saw the 1.0
version of this document.
This is the 1.1 version,
which at the time I'm recording this,
is a working draft.
I'm working off this version in this
lesson since it's more up to date and
will eventually become
the standard version.
This is the design pattern
we already saw for
a radio group, which gives us
the keyboard interaction and
also some more detailed advice on the
ARIA attributes which should be used.
The design pattern tells us that we need
to put our radio buttons in a container
element with a role of radiogroup,
give each one a role of radio, and
ensure that we set
aria-checked correctly.
So let's try that out.